[Music]
again quick reminder thursday september
24th at 7 p.m we're going to be doing a
live show
are you garbage at the punch line in
philadelphia pennsylvania come and check
us out
yeah guys it's going to be a good show
we're going to do a live stand up and a
live podcast with special guest
mike rainey from dadmy podcast so check
it out get your tickets
now yes sir hey gang it's your old pals
uncle hank and kippy just want to thank
you for tuning in to
ru garbage yeah guys make sure you
subscribe
that way you get the episode as they
come out you can also go to
gasdigitalnetwork.com use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and
hd streaming do it yeah
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley baby
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is
r u garbage the show where we sit down
with your favorite comedians
and find out if they grew up classy or
if they're absolute trash
i'm your host states foley coming at you
on yet another beautiful fall day
here in new york city as i say all the
time alive and well
kicking here in the big studio at cash
digital studios
my co-host all right the hymns are
working
yeah daddy get this guy on [ __ ]
rogaine weekly
because he's got the miracle cure gang
you know the drill
the next time you're reaching for a best
pal do yourself a [ __ ] favor
and you make it a kippy give it up for
kevin james ryan everybody
now with extra follicles hey dang what's
up thanks so much for tuning in
everybody that hairline is
[ __ ] fighting like a young bruce
willis he's like a [ __ ] fighter that
really turns it on in the eighth you
know what i mean
uh you know i was doing the rope-a-dope
the whole [ __ ] time
uh guys thanks so much for listening
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube subscribe there as well
also gas digital network you can sign up
if you want to get all the you know all
the perks from the [ __ ]
from the network you can sign up use
code ayg we get to wet our beaks a
little bit which is pretty big around
here you know
i like to make a couple of bucks you
save a couple of bucks it's a [ __ ]
win-win you know what i mean who doesn't
like money we all do so do that and also
tonight if you're listening to this the
day it comes out and you're in the
philadelphia jersey delaware
new york [ __ ] maryland air wherever
the [ __ ] you are
if you're within 700 miles of [ __ ]
the punch line in philadelphia
get your [ __ ] tickies and come out to
the live pod
we got [ __ ] special guest shane
gillis popping in
and from the dad meet podcast mr mike
[ __ ] rain
yeah so it's gonna be a [ __ ] hot one
uh we're gonna be doing a little bit of
stand up and then a live pod it's gonna
be [ __ ] dope so
go get those [ __ ] tickets everybody
not too late gang make a [ __ ] move
let's do it you only live once and you
never know when it's gonna end so come
out to the [ __ ] punchline have a good
time
but that is neither here nor there it
ain't because we could not be more
excited to have our incredibly special
guest here with us today
one of the most requested yeah yes this
guy's got to be a real dirtbag
because they came pouring in for him
ladies and gentlemen
you know him from uh former co-host of
the tim dylan's going to hell and of
course he is the host
of the amazing podcast comp ladies and
gentlemen do me a favor
give me a nice big round of applause for
the one the only ray comp
hello thank you for having me yes sir
thanks for doing it man
great to see we look like [ __ ]
brothers we could do a [ __ ] brother
comedy yeah we're probably yeah my dad
probably
uh did your mom's taxes yeah she got
around a little bit
ain't gonna lie yeah you two could
definitely be in like a you're both
truckers or something doing this
doing a long haul a buddy buddy taking
turns
but uh buddy thank you so much for
coming on the show thank you for doing
the show
like i said thanks for having me uh
everybody is wanted on here and we're so
glad that uh
that we got you here and uh we're both
very curious because you're
a little bit of a mystery to me uh
what's the what's the origin story of
ray kump
what's the back story well you know um
there's different like ways we can go
down this i mean
i don't know where you start you want
the easy road you want the hard road
i was a fat kid
no way um i guess you know
i get if we're gonna track down my
history it seems to be a lot of uh
i like i'm a shy kid but then when
people go after me
like i don't know is high school too
late are we are we trying to go back to
like when i was five like where are we
whatever
i'm from long island uh deer park uh
actually was born in queens but we moved
out because uh i guess my parents
started people were selling crack in the
neighborhood
i think they're just you know just white
flight probably okay but uh
you know it's i grew up i went to a
catholic school i didn't really have any
uh
friends in my neighborhood so all like
the weird uh
there's like a weird thing where like
like it was two different white trash
families there's me and like this other
family down the block and
we always thought they were trash it was
like today like
we were like the best yeah we were like
we're not as bad as the [ __ ] johnsons
yeah what was their last name i don't
know if i should go into that
i think one of them died in iraq so it'd
be kind of uh
you know oh okay i mean look it's war
prophet who cares
um but you know i i
i like the star trek and ghostbusters
and um my dad was an accountant
you know brothers and sisters i have one
brother
he used to always uh i don't know we
didn't get along that well
um i like him now but he's cool but like
there's really nothing there's nothing
i'm i don't have some backstory where
like i grew up in
you know west virginia and like [ __ ]
was sucking cold dick
i don't know where that was probably
you're staying like suburban upbringing
for the most
i
[Music]
what's your brother do now if you don't
mind me asking he's a computer guy who
[ __ ] knows what that means
probably just like you know sells child
porn to sex
you know predators no he's not but
whatever i mean who knows
everyone says they're a web developer
who knows what they're doing
that's true dude i don't [ __ ] know
the black web just telling people
ketamine
but uh yeah i don't know i don't really
have an identity or much memory before i
was like you know
15 i guess that's when they were kind of
weird yeah
uh i know at some point i started i was
getting picked on in high school and i
just started like
selectively acting out like they were
like
getting my face in the locker room and i
would just like get i would start
screaming at them i'm gonna come to your
house
and i'm gonna shoot myself on your front
lawn
that'll turn it on him yeah really that
was a curveball
yeah it's just that that's the thing i i
learned early on just to
be be something they can't have an
answer for sure like that
doesn't mean i exactly it doesn't mean
you have a nice life but you know it's
like they
they don't win either right and that's
my whole strategy
everything um if everybody loses we're
fine did you play any sports in high
school or anything like that
i played lacrosse for like a half a
semester
on academic probation my my family
wanted me to play i think they wanted me
to just
like not be just a disgusting fat turd
just like
smelling up the house all day so i tried
to go
and uh i don't know i i i
it wasn't my they sent me to [ __ ]
lacrosse camp that summer because my
brother wanted to go
okay and it was just like it was four
days of me just i know the first day
i [ __ ] randomly just like scooped the
ball came near me and i just scooped it
behind my back
and this guy starts screaming at me like
what are you doing you fat idiot
and it just happened to land in some
guy's stick so it's like
it looked like i made some amazing play
and then
every other moment after that was just
like they realized that was
blind luck that was funny uh yeah i
don't know these aren't like stories i
tend to tell you guys about sports i
i don't have anything we're just trying
to get we're trying to get a picture of
the child
trying to get a feel on you yeah sure
sure i mean i worked at a morgue for a
while that seems to
be okay performing the thing yeah that's
pretty well how old were you when you
started at the moment what'd you do
there
was like 20 i was a photographer i was
26 i guess i was a
hedgehog photographer i photographed the
autopsies yeah
you know x-rays and all that kind of um
fingerprinting a little bit seeing all
those dead bodies no
it was great it was fun as hell i'm not
like
i didn't grow up like with my dad's
[ __ ] killing deer in front of me but
like
and maybe that's why because i'm like oh
this would be cool i'm too disconnected
from depth
i need to have some depth in my life
okay yeah they're kind of i don't know
don't you don't feel like you you wish
you saw people killed in front of you
when you were a kid
it would be nice well i don't know
i saw men menace to society and i didn't
want to see any more death i'll tell you
that
yeah i cried at the shining i'm not
getting a job in the morning yeah
yeah i don't i don't want some guy from
the [ __ ] 1800s to have anything on me
you know
like oh you don't know what it smells
like when the [ __ ]
you know decomp corp shits itself and
yeah yeah i do i [ __ ]
i'm you know whatever i i took part in
the autopsies even though i wasn't
really supposed to
doing some semester after hours work
yeah well they have like old women it's
a county so they have these old women
who had been there for 40 years like
moving bodies for me onto the x-ray
table off and she's like i think she's a
bastard just like
this [ __ ] 800-pound guy's gonna fall
on her and all the other photographers
are just like letting it happen i'm like
[ __ ] so i [ __ ] just start you know
i start moving the bodies cleaning them
wiping their asses
uh whatever it takes you know it's it's
a whole
team player i like it yeah um how long
did you do that for
like three or four years damn um
it's a lot of fun i mean i don't know
it's just you just see [ __ ] you get to
see like
uh a lot of suicides a lot of murders
serial killers
um people get hit by trains you're like
you're picking people up and like
here's your leg and it's just like it's
like playing connect not connect four
what's the
mr potato head yeah but like if by
someone [ __ ] you know some guy who's
like wife left him so he jumped in front
of him i don't know i'm not making a lot
of suicide
i'm not a doctor sure yeah of course i'm
just kidding i'm not a doctor like doc
he's all over the place
these guys playing it fast and loose i
love it
meanwhile i'm going to ask you what kind
of [ __ ] frozen pizza yeah um
what uh okay did you did your the house
you grew up in was it like a
apartment townhouse condo giving a
normal
everything about me is just basic it's
just like you know it's fine
but it was kind of it was a little small
if we had those like [ __ ] weird
wood paddling on the floor i don't you
know
i just you make you make your own life
you don't [ __ ] you grow up in a
[ __ ] middle class uh bland existence
go [ __ ] you know go pick up a body
and see what it's how you feel
you don't have to like people get a
little hung up about like where did you
come from
like what did you [ __ ] you know do
you have a rough upbringing just make it
rough just [ __ ] get you know
i don't know i i'm insecure about the
fact that there's nothing to say here
about my childhood no
no no no listen we love there's nothing
better than boring suburban life
that's what the show's based on yeah
it's not we're not looking for you like
ah my [ __ ] uncle touch me we're not
looking for
any insane [ __ ] stories here oh boy
scout
i'm actually an eagles i'm an eagle
scout i forgot wow
i feel like those kids were always a
little weird though yeah a little out
there
yeah i didn't really want to do it but
like my scoutmaster like pleaded with me
because they convinced me that like
look you're going to look back in 15
years if you don't do this and you're
going to regret it
it's going to open doors for you no it
has done nothing to order open doors
yeah to his bedroom they always they
they sell you like they're in a [ __ ]
pyramid scheme they're like hey look
here's the way it works
if you [ __ ] if it's your resume and
you're matched up with you know you're
both in the same colleges now
but you put and then the separated thing
is that you're an eagle scout and he's
not they're gonna hire you
now first of all i don't nothing i have
nothing on my resume it's just
a morgue and uh you know threats of
suicide so
it's never gonna be the deciding factor
it doesn't tell you like the astronauts
are all those
apollo astronauts are all eagle scouts
as if like my fat
you know every one of my troopers is a
dirt bag none of us are astronauts
nobody's going to mars from gump's eagle
scout dude and for the for the audio
listener he is swinging a 2 liter of
doctor
diet doctor diet doctor prep by any
chance that's not a cherry dr pepper is
it
no i prefer the regular the cherries
just uh
yeah go ahead i recently had a cherry
vanilla dr pepper and it [ __ ] blew my
doors off
i think it was fantastic you know it's a
it's a classy drink it's uh
i'll wear it out of the wedding or you
know a funeral
what wedding are you going to the day of
diet dr pepper
i don't know their kid died so they like
they ended up getting divorced and got
remarried some chick like that you know
yeah all right well let's get in a
little are you garbage here all right
brother we're gonna ask you a series of
questions we just want you to answer
them open and honestly
uh if they you know stimulate any any
stories or anything please feel free
to elaborate uh you ready to rock and
roll
sure let's do it uh we'll start out with
uh some of the basics
that people want to know about you what
was the name of the street
that you grew up on uh kingston
street that doesn't seem too bad that
sounds all right
that would be like in a movie like down
there on kingston street you know what i
mean you guys is this all you like
stuff to steal my identity what's your
mother's maiden name we're gonna copy
your fingerprints too name your first
grade teacher like what was this [ __ ]
your first pet name um okay all right
uh what was the name of the grocery
store your parents went to growing up
uh it was called finest which i think
became a stopping shot but yeah it was
called finest
that's not too bad you guys ever had
that and uh wherever
berg you're from from outside of
philadelphia no no stopping shop
well but yeah finance was not finest it
was a
it was far from it it was uh you know
the meat was fine mostly
just okay that's what they wanted to
really cook it a little gray but you're
not gonna get sick most of the time
all right okay fair enough now you said
you grew up in a single family home
correct
so it was like yeah yeah yeah yeah there
was a garage involved
we had a garage yeah it was a big oil
spot in the middle uh
was there a second refrigerator in that
garage
not in the garage we had one in the
basement after a while because we got a
new fridge and then
they just put the other one in like next
to the oil burner yeah that's exactly
how we do it and what was in that fridge
downstairs was it sodas ice pops all
that kind of stuff
most of the time just writing vegetables
honestly i i forgot about i haven't done
this in years but yeah i would go down
there
and you open it up and like my mom would
just stick things in there and forget
about it and it was just like stalks of
uh celery and [ __ ]
cauliflower just like like like the soup
you know the soup that forms
oh yeah a lot of water a lot of moisture
yeah
so that was fun holy [ __ ] where did you
put yours
the question it revolves around uh
having a second refrigerator in the
garage that's usually for beers and ice
pops and stuff like that
really so much rotting rotting uh
cucumbers and it is a garbage it's a
garbage thing because you
don't want to like you're in your family
your parents can't get rid of that
fridge for some reason because they
think it's there's still
a lot of value so they just put it in
another room so it's
appreciated yeah you're just like
yes for sure get the blue book value on
the [ __ ] kenmore in the basement with
the with the carrots in it
what do you got kip um let's see this is
this is a big one will you
uh will you brush your teeth in the
shower
um i haven't brushed my teeth in like
six months
wow okay so where i make it fall out
i mean i i had i had two teeth that had
to get pulled like six months ago
and uh and they ended up convincing me
to like get implants for like it was
like they i ended up spending six grand
because they gave me a credit card and
i'm like i'm pretty sure they were wrong
because one time i like i [ __ ] broke
a tooth off eating a bean burrito from
taco bell
did you get the crunchy what's going on
no it's a soft that's how rotted the
tooth was it's like that like i'm just
eating a bean burrito maybe it was a
seven layer but definitely wasn't a
[ __ ] gordita
and uh i'm just chewing on it and i was
like what is
what's this bean burrito and i realized
my toots fallen into the beans
but not the whole thing half of it broke
off so i [ __ ]
uh so it's all pointy and [ __ ] just
jamming so i do
i go to work i was working in the
graveyard shifted the potato bread
warehouse at the time
and
a graveyard shift at a potato bread was
it was it meyers
potato bread no it's martin's martin i'm
sorry yeah
that's a pretty classy [ __ ]
opportunity that's the [ __ ] top of
the heap when it comes to potato
sure and uh yeah and they're also like
weirdly religious you go into the
warehouse it's just all these like
biblical quotes in the walls um and then
some guy like you know
doing taking a heroin [ __ ] in the
bathroom yeah you know
um the drivers aren't exactly the
[ __ ] you're not the king of england
you know
they're kind of they're blue collar guys
whatever yeah um
no so i go to work and all night just
[ __ ] like pointed to just jamming
into my tongue and i could barely talk
so i [ __ ]
i ended up going on to my friend's bread
route after you know i got out and we're
like
in the supermarket and i just go [ __ ]
this i grab a metal nail file
i started like it was like [ __ ] you
know a big window you have in the truck
side window yeah i just started [ __ ]
filing my tooth down like
in the [ __ ] window um and that was
fine and like yeah when
a few years later when i got to the
morgue i finally got removed but like
that my point is i don't think i think
they screwed me and made me get
six thousand dollar implants sure uh
somebody
gives you a little credit card that's
not in your best interest that's not in
your business
no sure but and even so that happened
and i
i brushed like two times since so i
don't know what's wrong with me it's i
think it's a psychological thing
you're telling us you don't brush your
teeth at all
uh if i have if i eat like ribs
i'll i'll i'll like you know i'll try to
jam it once over
yeah but no i don't like
there was a time when they did i don't
know what happened to me
are you garbage first man wow holy [ __ ]
now i know why everybody wanted you on
yeah jesus christ that's [ __ ] is that
bad
but yeah what do you mean six months
you're breaking your teeth on [ __ ]
burritos that's so good
yeah i have my flaws all right
i can see if he was like i went off
there you know a a piece of corn on the
cob and my tooth got stuck or something
but a [ __ ] bean burrito
no it's not it's not what you were the
they were they weren't structurally
sound at that point
the softest burrito doesn't get any
softer yeah get ellen
in there to take a look at that thing
damn okay oh
[ __ ] that is [ __ ] something else uh
let's go back to the house
um yeah take take me up uh at your
parents house uh did you guys have a uh
in the bathroom did you have a door for
the shower or a curtain for the shower
yeah it was one of those sliding things
uh we'd have a curtain
what did what'd your mom do for a living
did you tell us
my mom uh you know she did stuff for my
dad
so your dad did pretty good as an
accountant i would have to assume right
i did
fine he like i mean he made he had one
of those 15-year mortgages i think so it
was like you know everything was
like by the time i moved out he was
finally like doing okay but like
he has a weirdly sense of catholic
school and i ended up getting kicked out
anyway
but that was a lot of money uh so it
never felt like we had money i'm sure
you know it's like
he kind of just loaded like front loaded
his life and he would yell at me he was
screaming me sometimes like i want my
life back
because i was like i don't know i
[ __ ] like got chocolate on his guitar
or some [ __ ] he presented me um
but where's that i mean he's funny i was
not expecting a guitar
to come out after the chocolate wow
what was the uh the vacation situation
growing up did you guys go away
we went to lancaster a few times did you
like hershey lancaster
did you go to dutch wonderland i have no
memory of it but i'm pretty sure he did
once
but i don't remember there's a theme
park there right yeah it's real garbage
it's tough yeah
maybe we didn't go that because we went
to hershey hershey's right that's the
thing hershey's right there so why would
you go to the
dust it's like kind of like we had
adventure lands in long island it wasn't
that bad they actually did you know that
movie uh
the safety brothers movie with the
[ __ ] you see robert patterson
before good time that's the [ __ ]
place yeah yeah and uh well yeah because
to go to jersey to [ __ ] go great
adventure before hours but like you know
but it was it was
a relatively shitty park but uh hershey
was nice
hershey's all right yeah because we
never went there so we went there yeah
oh yeah yeah that's imaginable
but you go anywhere like would you go
down the shore at all i guess if you're
on long island the beach is kind of
close or the cumps not real beachbody
you weren't a hamptons family are you so
we were no no but we did go to gilgo
beach you know the place where the
oldest prostitutes were murdered
um
every analogy or simile
[Laughter]
it was like 10 years ago there was a
serial killer i was actually you know
part of the case i don't know if i could
talk about the details
i was taking pictures the more again
uh that makes sense okay all right yeah
it wasn't me relax but the point is
i was actually part of the case where i
got i got counseling i was in
adventureland at the time what are you
talking about
holy [ __ ] but uh we would go like you
know it was a nice beach back then
it got eroded over time i would go
boogie boarding uh
i didn't really know how so it would
just be some like you know i
got my mom got me like a bright pink
boogie board because it was cheaper
and uh which is fine nowadays that's
fine but like that back then there was
still
people would question your manhood yeah
oh for sure
for sure i used to hate that we always
got the shitty [ __ ] sleds we got the
shitty boogie boards
the shitty [ __ ] everything it was
there was never
it was never we never got the boogie
board that had like the plastic on the
bottom with the with the surf wax
the hard bottom was [ __ ] nice yeah
you had one my cousins had one them
[ __ ] [ __ ] people [ __ ] talk about
like oh my my parents were poor
or they [ __ ] you know my dad did
heroin yeah that's that's rough but it's
also like i
i had to get the [ __ ] the la gear
pump sneakers not the reebok ones
and that like you know it's all relative
unless you're a rich kid but you know
it's like my struggle is just as you
know sincere as
anyone else's sure yeah it was bad for
you so that's all you know yeah for sure
wasn't it was la gear hot for a minute
or am i nuts
for like a probably probably the la
lights were all right yeah that was part
of the la gear so when the when the
lights hit that was big
oh but then they didn't really do much
after that i don't think
yeah those pumps were garbage it was
like you remember like the the nike pump
had a little bit
look like a basketball yeah and the
other ones just looking inside that
vagina
like you're wanting a [ __ ]
shoes so did i do he's gonna be three
he's gonna be three two liters down
by the end of it how many of those do
you drink a day uh
two or three two or three
holy [ __ ] it's not gonna be that
it won't be the dr pepper that kills me
what's it going to be
probably me my own worst enemy
um say tease and if so what did you get
them
yeah this is the original i had the
original score i know they keep changing
them but
properly yeah yeah i'm going to guess
i'm going to say it was high
okay yeah i would say
yeah yeah all right it's 1280.
that's it's not great that's that's
above the curve
no it's solid but like it's a story in
my life because like if you hit 1400
then people treat you like you're like
but like 1280 you're just kind of a dumb
smart guy
you know it's just like no one no one's
gonna let you into their school because
i never did any work
so no one's gonna like it's like it was
an episode of saved by the bell where
zach gets like a 1500 for some reason
and all these schools which is like you
know i don't know why i referenced that
but the point is no one's going to be
coming to like
recruit me uh because of my favorite
1280 and like
it's just your c you're see average
you're no one's coming right i'm the
door
i'm i'm a c average you know gap toothed
wide-footed [ __ ] yeah dead people
shooting
did you end up going to college did you
go to school yeah i went i was doing i
was trying to do filmmaking at the time
so i went to like hofstra for a year
but like uh i took japanese and failed
uh i found some other stuff i didn't go
to class half the time and
um i would just go like this weird
little film lab they had which was like
um
it was like a vh like those combo vhs
machines that were like
and they had those and a bunch of like
old vhs tapes and i would just not go to
like japanese class or history class and
just watch
you know bear luchi movies or whatever
uh which i could have done at home so my
point is
like i guess i guess i was like a member
of college but yeah
i didn't really uh there was a paralegal
student for a while
but the whole time i i felt like i was i
didn't need this because i was you know
trying to make this movie about a pizza
place and these foam sword kids
and uh yeah i spent like i i was like a
feature-length film i
had like all these people doing it and
like it didn't ended up like falling
apart
like three quarters of the way through
but uh was the plot
exactly i mean the foam sword kids they
call them buffer swords these foam
swords and like they were like [ __ ] i
don't
it was like warping kind of you're
talking about or no yeah but they
weren't larping it was like
it was like before larping became a
thing i think i just happened to see
people doing it so i wrote a script
about like this guy tries to save a
pizza place for some reason so those
other kids try to
like start i don't i'll kill myself if i
try to remember the details
because i'm saying it i'm really i'm
remembering how [ __ ] dumb and
convoluted like
i i'm so embarrassed i like wasting
people's time don't be silly
no it was terrible
yeah i mean you know what did they some
people kill kids what did they kick you
out of catholic school for
i told this girl i was gonna blow up her
mother's uterus um
and look they took it totally out of
context
i need a couple of ciggies it wasn't
like a threat
i wasn't like [ __ ] like trying to
rape this girl or anything it was like
[ __ ] the normal
uh she was this girl who my friend knew
who helped me with the filmmaking stuff
and he said that she would be able to
get us guns because her dad's a cop
which i don't even like the cr it's
crazy that i think about it now like
why would that mean like a cop is the
last person to like let her friends kids
get take his gun
but whatever but like you know so i was
talking to her about it
in class one day and she [ __ ] uh
starts going i'm like oh what kind of
guns do you have and she's like oh i
think he has like a
glock and i'm like oh my dad's got an
anti-aircraft gun the [ __ ]
abrams like this dumbest like i was just
trying over the top yeah
yeah and like so it was basically i
forget what happened her boyfriend
thought i was
like being weird to her so he started
giving me [ __ ] and i just started
yelling at him and thought well we
really
i'll [ __ ] blow me out of his room and
i'm like so there was a commotion
but then it was also combined with the
fact that i was talking it was like
right after columbine
so they felt like they people someone
that's in that class took my
claim of having an abrams tank in my
backyard like seriously
[Laughter]
so they made me like this made me leave
i had to go like it was my senior year
uh like this last semester so last
semester of my senior year i had to go
to public school
which was so much better it was just
weird people like why are you here now
like whatever your parents kind of
forced you to go to catholic school
yeah basically they kept you know they
kind of pressure like they kept losing
a threat like if you don't [ __ ] shape
up we're going to send you your
everything
much better at school like i went to
again the catholic exploit went to
wasn't
a good school it was like a really
everything was dilapidated
uh like because i was saying i don't
know if anyone was looking out i went to
st
john's saint anthony's was a much nicer
school i even i got into it but like
whether my friends were going in
but like everything was just fun the
teachers were idiots
uh the [ __ ] the the science labs
was from the 60s uh it was just nonsense
i can't learn like this because the
other school was like yeah like
in dick's hills or whatever like he's
like rich you know like jets players
live where
the [ __ ] and like you know they give
endowments to school
like you know i don't know so i'm just i
didn't grow like
the money was spent poorly i guess is
the point my dad
my dad tried to give me a good education
you know he fumbled it in the prop you
know
he should have sent me like some you
know if you're gonna spend the money
making sure
that right yeah yeah do a little
research is what you're saying how
pissed were they
how pissed were they when you got kicked
out of catholic school were they man
they weren't it was uh i think at that
point
just turned into rodney dangerfield
yeah at that point they were kind of
like it was just every step of the way
like you know it was just like why can't
you just act like an old person
and so when that like when that happens
it's like oh maybe it'll shape up maybe
we'll shape up
and then like that happens it's kind of
like i think my dad actually like hugged
me
for the first time in my life just
because uh i think he i think he thought
i was just gonna like end up becoming a
suicidal bomb uh like i think he kind of
quickly i mean i don't know if we're
that far off
to be honest with you sure you know it's
kind of thing where it's so
dumb and bad oh this kid's like not a
normal person he's never gonna
work at a bank he's like this is fine as
long as he's not like killing women he's
fine
that's what that's not not normal you
are a normal person buddy what are you
talking about you're absolutely [ __ ]
fantastic oh i know i love myself i'm
just you know
that's right switch is like
all right let's get back to some
questions here what do we got
uh have you ever bought a product that
was as seen on tv
uh we had the ronpo peel [ __ ]
pasta maker no the rotisserie chicken
[ __ ] this guy's got [ __ ] cake you got
ronco money what are you talking about
you're selling yourself
short yeah well i think i think my mom
would just like
because i think it's a source of a lot
of conflict because you just buy stuff
over home shopping network all the time
and we didn't have the money it would be
like i'd hear screaming in the night
another vegetable peel or die in
and my grandma did the same thing my
grandma like why is she she died she
woke up one day
and just [ __ ] like her bed and
always goes back to death with this guy
he's like the [ __ ] grim reaper what's
going on
they found out that she had just been
holding in her ship for two weeks
well that's happened to explain to me i
don't know like it seems weird to say
that but like
oh my god she wouldn't go to the doctor
uh so she she had sepsis do a nine part
[ __ ] are you garbage with you dude
this is insane
he was killed foley so she had uh
she had [ __ ] uh sepsis which is when
like [ __ ] gets in your blood
which is a good thing that happens like
you just get into your blood so
she died like whatever is you know a few
days later but uh
they found out like when they started
looking like she had been like my
grandpa had run like a small company
that was like kind of it was kind of
thing where enough to like live for 20
years
without like you know being a pauper but
it wasn't like rich you know but like
you know
i had like you know a couple of dollars
and whatever and she spent it all on
like
a shopping bag what do you call those
things handbags and like
qvc and [ __ ] like that yeah yeah and
like and just kind of fl so i don't know
it's a lot of
debt in my uh like talking about nike
merchandise like a [ __ ] gucci handbag
or uh
no there's nothing you could sell like
something was like a lion on it or
something you know like something weird
embroidered or
[ __ ] you know act now only 10 left
hold on i gotta say this tina fey
handbag or some [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah the suzanne summers
[ __ ] leggings or some [ __ ]
i gotta say the [ __ ] dude to have the
[ __ ] the set it and forget it dude
that's
huge that's nice man i've never used it
did you guys actually use it did it make
good we use it like
either two or three times it came out
good but we didn't share the [ __ ] she
would buy the gimmicky thing she'd buy
the [ __ ]
the brit the tiles for the pink pizza in
the in the oven
and she made the pizza once or twice it
was good but you know i think
she's like me she'll like you know get
really into something like
the morgue and then like you know it
only lasts for a little bit of time and
then you [ __ ]
you know i got i'm mercurial as well as
my point okay i got it from her
and now would you say now that you're a
rotisserie chicken guy like
would you have a roto now i mean i
thought about that i just want an air
fryer which is pretty dope
oh all things coming up come on
all right coming through yeah guys got a
little bit of cash on it org clouds are
part in here
yeah no it's uh things are things are uh
taking a turn for the better
um it makes it mix you wouldn't think it
makes steak but it makes steak pretty
damn well too that's immediate you know
our coating and the pink in the middle
whatever i mean it's great
airfryer to a whole turkey if you need
yeah
yeah you're i gotta say i don't we've
met i think once or twice in person but
you're a little bonker
i said what's up outside of a show but
dude you're [ __ ] you you're cuffed
from another cloth this guy's nuts
great comp just [ __ ] let him go get
out of his way this is something else
my favorite thing about you is when you
talk and then you you disagree with the
statement you just said then disagree
with that you're like it's [ __ ]
yeah it's it's a beautiful thing that's
just that's
a constant battle yeah which is pure
comedy which is great what'd you have
for lunch that's uh
what did you what was the last meal you
had today mr cump
did i eat today i'm trying to remember
um come on buddy
i think i i i we're all friends here
right what are we talking about
no i had some i had some keto peanut
butter um
i'm doing a keto diet so i i don't
usually buy these keto gimmick things i
just eat the meat
and like you know and some spinach maybe
but like i i decided this time to like
you know maybe i'll
treat myself and get some of these you
know amenities that you know
whatever um have you seen any progress
have you lost any lbs
huh yeah yeah a little bit you know it's
still in the early stage so i'm not at
the beginning of phases
like a week and a half so i mean you
have to get into ketosis
i'm not a doctor again but you know it's
like thing
for a couple months in uh in the summer
and i was just [ __ ] eating like a
pound of turkey and [ __ ] a half a
pound of cheese
every day yeah it's a fine job too oh
jesus oh yeah [ __ ] pizza leather
i [ __ ] made um chicken yesterday like
drinking drumsticks and then
you've probably heard of it the pork
rind thing i did for the first time
when you like coat the chicken and pork
rinds which should be
the most like this is how you like that
should be the only thing you tell people
are you garbage like it's the most
despicable thing i remember someone
telling me about years ago
and even i was like you sound like a
slob
right that sounds terrible dude yeah
using pork rinds as a coating
but like everything it's the most common
thing on keto every classy [ __ ]
san francisco chef whatever the [ __ ] you
know mike molecular just showing me
they're all doing it and it's just like
how is this
how am i bad but this is [ __ ] fun i
mean it was great though
you kind of seem like a guy who would
deep fry his turkey on thanksgiving you
a guy who deep fries a turkey
no because my parents are really over
really overprotective so they would
never do stuff like that
it would always be maybe that's part of
the problem because it would always just
be like
putting the feet like just kind of what
you going
brow beating me about like don't ever
but they would say when i was like 10.
don't ever fry a turkey it'll [ __ ] it'll
blow up it'll burn your face off
i don't cook eggs why are you even
telling me this
[Laughter]
are they in shape people or are they
having
fat people um my dad's like having big
jars
i can picture your dad i can 100 i've
never seen him but i could probably
i could probably sketch him it's
basically me but just a more
disappointed look in his face
more beating down man yeah like oh look
what my kids become
like this what was that uh what was that
brand of pretzels you were talking about
you said he had a big
big jug of pretzels uh whether they saw
the price club it was uh probably
snyder's or who knows
it's just the ones with the peanut
butter in them
the little nuggets no that that that
wasn't the common thing in my house we
just
my dad loved just hard pretzels just
hard crunchy
just like he you know he loves carbs he
loves he watched jackie chan movies on a
small tv
in the kitchen and just eat pretzels
dude the small tv in the kitchen's a
trash movie you got to have that little
nine incher in there
oh yeah it's trashy yeah when you guys
would have dinner growing up would it
most would you
would there be like a set dinner time
and that you guys would eat together as
a family
it wasn't that put together but we
definitely ate dinner most nights
together
but now i remember they bring up a
memory again
i felt this is a betrayal because i
[ __ ]
uh we used to have a tv right and like
we have to pull the tv
like the table out and i said i was the
one who had to sit
like where the tv was facing the other
way so i couldn't see the tv
every night in the [ __ ] again this is
like this is the problem with childhood
like
it makes me want homicidal to think
about that but it's not really a great
story stop talking about killing
yourself
and killing people homicide i'm not
suicidal
um oh yeah so we had a tv
another question tv yeah you watch
yeah no did you watch tv while you were
eating dinner
i well that's my point the rest of the
family did but his back was
this is crazy it's gonna look like a
[ __ ] there's gonna be red strings all
over i don't know [ __ ] episode notes
to this
oh man the [ __ ] mind of ray kump is
[ __ ]
something else hey gang today's episode
is brought to you by
sheath underwear sheath makes the
softest most most comfortable boxer
briefs i have ever worn i literally have
them on
right now if you're sick of boxes that
are too loose or briefs that are too
tight
sheath is for you here's what makes
sheath unique
it's a stretchy fabric it's made out of
moisture wicking technology
it feels silky and keeps everything cool
comfortable and
in place kippy's little peepee is in his
home daddy
it's the perfect underwear for working
out plus it's the most unique thing
about sheath
is they have these dual pouches which
sounds crazy if you don't know what it
is but they keep your man parts
separated it prevents them from sticking
together
this is huge for working out being in
hot environments or if you just want to
make your fall activities a little more
enjoyable
you know will make the pumpkin picking a
little more fun making sure your balls
ain't on your thighs you know what i
mean
sheath underwear will make that happen
no more chafing no more gross ball sweat
just
comfort and support for your boys now
for some of you might not be interested
in separating your man parts i still
recommend sheaths
you can wear like any other box or brief
and it's crazy comfortable you can go in
the pouch out of the pouch balls in
weaner in whatever you want to do
and one more thing they look good and it
makes you look like you're packing it
gives you a little fluff it makes you
look real nice when you're walking
around the apartment
nothing wrong with that no buddy and we
could use it
um or if you're packing really if you're
already packing it makes you look like
you're really packing you know what i
mean get you pulled over for
carrying so go to sheathunderware.com to
get a pair of these most comfortable
underwear
you will ever own and if you use the
promo code garbage
you'll save 20 off your order that
sheath underwear dot com
use the code garbage for twenty percent
off
now back to the show this is
[ __ ] bonko's what about uh sky's
bonkos what was that what was the how
dude him taking this first of all that
two liter looks like a [ __ ] 20 ounce
in your hand
you said he's got a two liter and i saw
it and i go no that's a 20 that's 20
ounce and then
yeah what about the holidays what were
the holidays like at the gump household
and do you have do you have cousins and
[ __ ] like that in the area
no i mean i i only have two cousins and
they were both like a lot younger than
me growing up so
we never they they lived in like the
city
uh queens or whatever so we never got
bonded i would see him once a year
and i didn't like him very much at the
time um well they didn't like it
but what am i gonna you know when you're
15 or 20 what are you gonna say is i'm
six-year-old don't you yeah sure
creep so it's like you know oh how's
school going shut the [ __ ] up
like you have mrs davis yeah um
man i probably should have taken him to
a movie or something i'm a bad uncle or
a cousin
okay all right fine but yeah i don't
know so
you're a legit lunatic
they were fine i mean my grandpa was in
the vermont
vermont uh the german army in world war
ii
jesus christ
he wasn't a nazi uh he was a member of
the nazi party but you know he spent
seven years in the gulag
uh oh yeah so yeah they told me for
years he was in a british pow camp but
then like after he died or right before
they were like
oh we actually found out it wasn't it
was actually a russian prison i'm like
what like which is just you know a lot
worse i mean
oh my god i can't imagine yeah i didn't
talk about he was
he worked for boris head he was fine he
wasn't like he didn't talk he was bore's
heads wow he was
a german he was in the german army
during world war ii but somehow ended up
living over here in america
yeah i mean look dude look first of all
i don't know why you're surprised
because the ceo like
if the investor like the cia brought
over like all the top nazis so like sure
of course you know
to run the con not just not just you
know the apollo missions like everything
[ __ ] finance
whatever alan delusion the whole [ __ ]
thing you know my grandpa was just some
schmuck who drove a truck
and you know [ __ ] ended up cutting
beef for a living you know this is not
the [ __ ]
this is not some [ __ ] nazi hunter
[ __ ] he's not verner von braun or
whoever the guy wasn't started nasa yeah
he wasn't
i don't i don't know we didn't talk
about that much my grandma was mad just
because like i think her family had some
money before the war
and then like she and then afterwards
you know the whole the place got bombed
to [ __ ] so
all the money was gone and so she she
hated hitler for that reason at least
well that's good because again they
weren't rich
it's dark i don't know he's fine he's
dead he's dead now we're going to i
can't kill my grandpa now
he's dead i don't want you to kill your
grandpa
i feel like i'm an accessory to
something i'm not sure what it is yet
but i feel like i'm an accessory
i don't know if i see somebody with
their hands tied running behind you in
the [ __ ] video we're cutting the feed
what about okay so what about the
holidays did i ask this i don't know i
don't know where we got i don't know
what was it what was it wait what was a
what was a comp family christmas like
we'd make britken which was a
it was basically a cake made out of dead
people
and a little board that's some boris
we had opened it was an open face
sandwich that had mayonnaise and butter
and then krakow which is kind of like a
spicy bologna
polish i think and then a little bit of
ham and then
a pickle and a slice of egg
and they told me and they told me it was
some kind of tradition but when i grew
up i realized it was just some
just like it was just cold custom it's
tasty though it's a good combination
but like they love to like make up these
fake traditions and tell me like oh this
just goes back to
but no i've talked to any german people
no one's ever heard of this stuff yeah
my wife's german and i've never heard of
that ever
i think we need to talk to mr and mrs
cump to be honest we've got to get
them in here for some questioning yeah
some hard questions what uh did you guys
do a real christmas tree or a fake
christmas tree
i always had a fake one uh but i took
this my mom was really into it she had a
lot of
uh those little toy ornaments and stuff
and like trinkets
it was it was a whole three or four day
process to make the tree up you know it
was like
um it wasn't just these dumb balls of
people up there which is what i would do
i would just [ __ ] you know
i would just shove like i would just
spray cheese on it easy cheese
um do you have any of that in your
household currently
you no i never actually never bought it
i mean it should i mean it's great
i'm not sure keto is it keto friendly ah
it's not cheese so it's you know
i think okay yeah i think you're i think
you'd be all right would your mom do
decorations outside like
on the lawn and stuff like that we
weren't big like that we would have like
one
weirdly pathetic like plastic santa uh
and she was really religious so she put
the angels up she loved having those
[ __ ] angels
or some dumb nativity scene he had a
relativity i always thought nativity
was so creepy when i would write weird
yeah
i remember i was a kid they tried to
make me be like i was like a bait like a
toddler or something they try to make me
be jesus in the live nativity and i'm
like yeah i remember at that point i'm
like dude i don't like the way this is
shaping up
how was the audition
my agent got me the thing got you the
gig um
ray let me ask you this what was your
first car my friend
it was a 1979 mercedes
what uh it was i don't know how i got
roped into this
um his grandpa drove it over yeah
well my dad got into this kick of like
uh buying like old mercedes because it's
not that expensive
yeah was it indianapolis was it all
diesel yeah yeah
and like yeah well they handle well like
it's kind of everything about the car is
nicer than like
like later on i had like a sentra right
nissan whatever
should i crash into someone but like i'm
saying it's like
you crashed into who someone federal
agents that's fine
uh i don't know what
was it really federal agents yeah there
was like two federal agents on their way
like
it was like 2 a.m and they were on their
way to the airport and i wasn't drunk it
was fine
uh it's not a great story i always
thought it was kind of shifty because
like
they they i feel like they were on their
way to do something weird because they
were like very much like just just uh
we're gonna go
the cops will be here soon but uh it was
my fault the accident i fell asleep you
know
for a moment while i was driving um
there wasn't a point in the story the
point is like
the car wasn't as nice yeah of course
you know but that being said the problem
is the [ __ ] thing is like uh
don't pick up these birdies the turbo
diesels did but mine
so i'd like to learn to drive by like it
would take me like literally
20 seconds to like get to 60. so merging
was a bit of a problem
it sounded like an old boat trying to
turn it off right now yeah they ran
forever though man
those [ __ ] diesels were so good
no they were they were nice i mean when
i got to central i bought new
uh it was a dumb move i kind of wanted
to have a new car for once
um and like everything about you you
missed like the turning radius and just
the [ __ ]
the handling it's just like if you can
you know
get an older one like you know there's
something i won't get a jaguar maybe i
don't drive anymore
i would love to see you driving that
[ __ ] old mercedes diesel holy [ __ ]
that must be a sight you were you in
high school with that car
no i i like like december for um
what do you call it college i got it
yeah so i never drove in high school
because a little [ __ ] boy
i was too busy trying to make this pizza
movie
wait you were in high school trying to
get that pizza movie made
yeah yeah but again i should have
[ __ ] been trying to you know
get laid or something you know get some
drugs but you know in hindsight i'm
saying
i was very ambitious are you in a
relationship now right
oh yeah lucy steiner she's a comedian we
live together she's great i love her
we have we have you know a podcast for
our own too you can listen to that
sometime yeah plug it what is it plug it
up uh i
love it our love is disgusting okay
nice yeah all right let's get back i got
one here for ya
let's see i'm shaking by the way i don't
know i don't know if it's coming across
i'm literally shaking he's got you got
me on my toes i don't know what the
[ __ ] going on to be honest this is a
story um
let's see let's see what's this one have
you ever
um hmm have you ever been cosmic bowling
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] is that like midnight
bowling where they like lock you in and
it's all black lights
no just no i was probably i was part of
a bowling league for a little bit but uh
no that wasn't it was like a saturday
morning thing yeah
i think you were trying to get nailed by
the [ __ ] bowling alley
no it was like there was no cosmic
bowling it was like midnight bowling you
would go
and like it was like you're going to
find your wife or something
what i was cosmic it was midnight
bowling it was a lock-in
they locked you in yeah it was like you
from like 12 to six or something it was
like
you just like [ __ ] bowled all night i
don't [ __ ] know i thought
six hours i thought goo somebody i
thought it was something
i thought cup was weird what the [ __ ]
you're midnight bowling but i mentioned
it
who ran
[Laughter]
the only rule was no bottoms
you guys have never done bottomless
bowling wait you've never bowled naked
holy [ __ ] were you a packed lunch kid in
high school or did you buy your lunch
um i think half the time it was kind of
inconsistent
uh but yeah i remember as a kid i
remember because distinctly remember
getting
ham sandwiches that were totally i was
in first grade though
they were toasted and mustard and that
was nice and then one time we got like
uh
one time i got [ __ ] uh the school
lunch it was like it was his hamburger
that was like i mean it was probably
just white american cheese but i didn't
expect it like
i looked down to ham cheeseburgers i'm
eating it it's all white
and for some reason it really creeped me
out and i vomited all over the lunchroom
table
um so i don't know um did they ask you a
question
i guess you're [ __ ]
crazy all right i got one this is uh
let's say you're in a public restroom
and you have to take a you have to take
a [ __ ]
how do you clean the public restroom do
you put toilet paper down do you wipe it
or do you just go bare ass i don't care
and we're having at it
well here's the thing i never used to
like [ __ ] in public at all ever
like you know i went to camp one one
week a year or every year
and the first year i went in rhode
island i didn't [ __ ] for the whole week
i literally held [ __ ] in it's crazy it's
like um
because i had like you know get it from
your grandmom i guess huh
yeah i was impressed it runs in the
family
exactly or it doesn't right that that
that being said i can [ __ ] anywhere now
uh i'm pretty i'm i'm kind of proud of
the fact that like i don't like we gotta
wipe the sh like who cares
you're [ __ ] out who cares if
someone's [ __ ] is on we're gonna catch
like a disease from [ __ ]
yeah i agree with you 100 big guy i'm
i'll maybe if there's if i see like a
little droplet of pee
i'll take a pull a little toilet paper
out i'll flush the toilet once
i'll dab a little bit of toilet paper in
the water and
and wipe it off and then maybe dry it
off and then sit and do my thing i don't
do the [ __ ]
toilet paper on the seat or anything
like that no i think it's in your ass
and it's just [ __ ]
i'm always afraid it's going to be stuck
to my ass when i get up yeah plus i need
this i need the
plastic of the seat to stretch my butt
cheeks out
so i can open up to the valve drop the
bombay doors you know what i mean
absolutely 20 seconds over tokyo welcome
welcome to the name
oh god holy [ __ ] have you
uh have you ever worked and been
involved with a
local um a local parade
uh i'm trying to think about parades
i don't think so i know i know one time
i went to
some amusement park with a bunch of
blind kids but uh
that but they were blind like adults or
handicapped adults but
it wasn't a parade uh why did you go oh
wait
i don't know my dad was in the lions
club
which is like one of those like things
like the you know the elk lodge or
whatever with
some eye doctor who like you know as a
pro bono
but i didn't know where they were so we
had these random blind people all around
me when i was a kid
and i just don't explain to me that it's
like oh they're gold
he's the guy's name was goldie and they
would explain like you know no one
explained it to me that he was like an
optometrist and like
it was just like here's all those blind
friends and like
i was trying to talk to my parents and
my parents would be like don't talk to
him
but in hindsight i think they were just
blind i don't think they were
handicapped so like
if they were i can't target handicapped
people it seems weird um
it was a confusing memory named goldie
what kind of
probably gold goldblum or something
right yeah probably
yeah come on down the goldies i dot
there's probably some anti-semitic uh
thing that's just but yeah but they
meant well but
it was a it was a bonding thing
okay um are you a bagel bites guy or are
you a pizza roll guy
i pay you for a pizza roll
i prefer a pizza roll right now uh i
think i ate i've
i think i've eaten more bagel bites but
i those pizza rolls are
satisfying how did all right now i gotta
follow up how did you make the bagel
bites
do you do a toaster oven the oven or do
you microwave them
i mean i i don't endorse this but i
think i it was a kid i would have
microwaved them because
a greedy little pig who like had to have
it now yeah i was the same
fat kid i couldn't wait dude the thought
of turning on the toaster or even worse
the oven
yeah to warm up to make elio's pizza or
something get the
i was like microwave it i don't give a
[ __ ] 100
uh so yeah so but the pizza rolls are uh
they're pretty classy what is your no
they are in fact
carpet what is your go-to
ma big franchise pizza delivery are you
a domino's you a pizza hut papa john's
little caesars
what are you well here's the problem if
i said pizza hut it would sound like oh
pizza is great
but when i was a kid it was fantastic
big pizza hut heads yeah huge it's
garbage now right from my experience so
like
well they don't go to the restaurants
it's more like the express and stuff you
know what i mean just like that yeah
that's no good
so i guess dom i mean papa john's is
pretty i mean i've gotten pretty sick
i remember i got sick uh i ate one of
those
uh little caesars um those things with
regular pizzas
but like you know they're not fresh and
red either like they've been sitting
around for six hours or whatever
i could see that i could see it was like
this doesn't seem like a pizza
but i took it anyway and i ate the whole
thing and then like i
it felt like i feel like i had cardboard
inside me for an entire day in his head
he probably cardboard the box dude it's
possible i guess
stuck to it i feel like i hadn't boarded
me for all day
you know i'll answer your questions
sincerely though i i i don't know
buddy
i love a good slice in a mall food court
yeah it's like you go for i mean it's
what's nice is the molds they weren't
even in the food court at least in my
mall
it was like a it was next to the macy's
or something so
yeah like tomorrow always had like the
[ __ ] corner real estate
right before whatever the two bookend
big department stores were
it was not let's just get the the
spinach and broccoli stuff slice
uh which is not it's not a healthy show
i mean it's like
it's a little healthy i could have it
with mom no but it was so good
um yeah then just you know [ __ ] for an
hour
uh and like the [ __ ] macy's
jesus holy [ __ ] ray cump man you [ __ ]
blew our doors off
what else you got for him kip um
let's see here have you ever had a pet
bird a lizard a snake and a guano what
were the
pets like don't go down this road
well i had two hamsters ones like five
but they only lasted a year or two
uh bonkers and boomerang but then we got
fish
at one point and then like goldfish or
like a proper
aquarium well so i basically i was at
one of these like
how used festival things and like you
would do the thing with the ball
when you throw the ball into the fish i
won me and my brother both won fishes
so like we we and we got a tank in the
store
and everyone's telling you these things
don't die in a week and i don't know
where that's
they lasted for like two years but we
also started adding more gold but we
didn't buy like [ __ ] tetra or
whatever the [ __ ] people were like
yeah fish or whatever five dollar fish
or ten dollar fish whatever we throw
them in there we had
so we had a few ones it was a
handicapped um blind guy
it was it was a bubble those big bubble
eye things you know what i'm talking
about
yeah bubble fish so it was one of those
but like one of them was deflated and
you still like swimming around in
circles
uh we called him gomez um
because you know for like adam's family
it doesn't matter point is he was a
but he died and like i remember my mom
and brother crying about it and
i mean i have empathy look at me i'm not
some [ __ ] sociopath but i felt weird
like
this is just a dumb fish but they seemed
to really i mean they had
we had i don't know they were fine they
were fine fish we buried them though
which is weird for goldfish i've buried
it we have shoot before yeah where'd you
bury
them we it's just like the flower
bay in the backyard and like we put like
a wood tombstone on top of it
um i don't know and then we had these
cats
well i wasn't allowed to have a cat
because my dad was allergic supposedly
but then i'm like you know so i'm ready
to move out i'm like years later
uh i'm like they're they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] around with these neighborhood
cats
they're like feeding them and [ __ ] like
these cats come by and you start leaving
food out
and there was this one like cat that was
like all [ __ ]
you know like whatever the [ __ ] it's
like yo farrell and [ __ ]
uh and they called the smedley and they
got to come live with them
and then like my dad's all of a sudden
like [ __ ] petting cats and
i'm loving it and i want i'm it's
enraging but
they end up getting murdered by our
neighbors like because my mom would just
feed these hats
your parents chopped them up
the cats they would feed these cats and
like the neighbors next door would get
pissed because she says
the neighbor would like sit in the grass
and just like pick weeds out of the
grass oh it was bizarre but like
the cats would [ __ ] in the grass and
she'd be like hey can you not feed the
cats because they're [ __ ] over my
grass
and my mom's like catch the only [ __ ]
and when they can bury it you're wrong
which is not true it's like if you give
them a litter box and [ __ ] litter box
but they'll absolutely just [ __ ]
anywhere if you live like they own a
litter box
so they got like you know because
basically what happened was
these cats started having like getting
all you know uh murked up they get
[ __ ]
like how do you explain the symptoms
they were like woozy
they were like all right i'm like bleach
or something antifreeze cats love
antifreeze you pour some energy freeze
he's sweet to them so just drink it up
so i know
and so like uh i would take it to i took
one of the morgue once and the doctor
almost autopsy dipped
and she's like ah these won't be binding
results because i'm not technically a
crypto
what they call is a different kind of
autopsy doctor um
but she was really into castle she
almost autopsies the cat but we didn't
do that
but uh but no they were like they
murdered for the cats
jesus christ
good lord gotta let that one bleed a
little bit
mr ray i've been a cat for a while i
have to give it away from a named after
an economist
it was named murray why did you give it
away uh i was moving to the city it was
i gave this one i got you know so it's a
nice home someone wanted a cat i'm like
i really can't afford
a neighbor was it no yeah
you got any extra antifreeze on
i got i got one final one um
do you currently have any posters in
your apartment right now
no i have some pictures i painted but uh
okay
if you can see it that's one that's a
picture of the morgue
uh if you see in the background a little
bit of uh don't worry about it it's a
i i i started painting with the more
just you know weird
like the you know the bloody the bloody
clothes or like [ __ ] some
decomp whatever i mean it's fine i'm i'm
not i'm not picasso
no no one's claiming you might be closer
to van gogh
why people have posters now is that sort
of thing no i was just trying to i don't
know
buddy we've done we've sat here with
about [ __ ] 40 people so far
i can't get a read on you i don't i
don't i have no idea
i'm taking a shower after this
oh my god ray thank you so much for
sitting down with us buddy uh is there
anything you want to folks out there to
know where they can find you uh
the podcasts all that stuff plug-in yeah
you can follow me you can follow me on
twitter and instagram
raycomp k-u-m-p uh my podcast is called
comp
you can get it on youtube or anywhere
you get podcasts and if you like this
it's more it's just a lot of uh
just kind of stream of consciousness and
just kind of chaotic i just fight with
myself the whole time it's fun
i mean it works somehow well i got to be
honest with you i don't know how you
could not [ __ ] like this because
i'm telling you right now this is the
most interesting episode that we've ever
seen you're a [ __ ]
wild dude you are [ __ ] thank you you
are a gem
100 funny through and throughout yeah
i'm not even gonna i'm not even gonna
say
that you're garbage or or or that right
you're classy
yeah you're an enigma wrapped in a
riddle
drinking diet dr pepper that's all i can
[ __ ] say
that's great you guys are cool too i
like you guys oh thank you ladies and
gentlemen mr ray kump
ray thank you so much buddy you'd be
safe out there and uh
we love you man that was funny that was
great dude thank you
yeah what do you got for me uh just make
sure you rate review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube you
subscribe there as well and also philly
jersey delaware new york wherever the
[ __ ] you are
get your tickets for the punch line
tonight
in philadelphia thursday it's the only
night it's happening so get them while
they're hot
we'll see you next time